a lot of news tight I want to get it in
our top story something that Trump will
likely confront tonight head-on at his
rally yesterday an anonymous figure
claiming to be a senior official in the
Trump administration authoring an op-ed
in The New York Times
bashing the president and his agenda and
telling lies
now the deep state unelected Washington
bureaucrat actually thinks he or she
knows more than you they know more about
who should be President your vote to
them means nothing we are smelling
Walmart irredeemable deplorable to them
all while this anonymous figure hides
behind the liberal New York Times they
are complicit in this now the Washington
Post get this reporting that sleeper
cells have awoken inside the executive
branch of the United States of America
think about that a sleeper cell a senior
official who might have access to
top-secret classified information who
might have privileged privileged insider
knowledge about sources and methods
that's people's lives now actively
working within our government against
your commander in chief
the media won't say this I will this is
extraordinarily dangerous to this great
constitutional republic and the
disgusting hey trump media they are
complicit in this cowardly betrayal
moments ago President Trump tweeted the
following are the investigative
so-called journalists of the New York
Times are they going to investigate
themselves who is the anonymous letter
writer of course this coward could be
one of literally hundreds of senior
level employees in the executive branch
we know that Trump's senior cabinet
members and close advisers are all
vehement ly denying writing this op-ed
tonight we're calling whoever you are
come forward you have purposely
mischaracterized the president's
conservative policies in your op-ed in
other words you're lying about his
effective handling of the economy North
Korea his tough approach towards Russia
you obviously have your
agenda your own political personal bias
you are an unelected unaccountable
anonymous official the American people
did not hire you to do this you have
access perhaps to intelligence methods
do you have knowledge of the president's
plans to defend America if so are you
gonna try to undermine that it's the
right thing to do if you really care
about the countries you so claim to do
as a super Patriot come forward this
country safety is obviously not the goal
of whoever this mysterious figure is nor
does the corrupt media in this country
even care what would happen if resistant
sleeper cells had emerged in Obama's
White House with the media be all in on
that this is all political working in
the shadows undermining a-sitting duly
elected president from within these are
the actions of a deep state super
patriot who thinks they know better than
you we us we the people these are
actions of someone who thinks Trump
never deserve to be President that we we
were all wrong these are the actions of
someone who cares what about democracy
and the sanctity of your vote no and
what does the op-ed author mean what
does he mean when he writes this until
one way or another it's over meaning the
Trump presidency is that a threat to the
President of the United States one way
or another what does that mean because
that can be interpreted as a threat to
the president I hope the Secret Service
is looking now sooner or later whoever
you are you'll be gone and bygone I mean
caught exposed fired and probably held
accountable for these horrible deeds
whatever you've done now we turn to
another top story this is huge news
tonight breaking only minutes ago the
hills John Solomon reporting that
Christopher Steele's phony Russian
dossier was likely the basis for the
ongoing witch-hunt into truck Russia
so-called collusion after it was pushed
by several high-ranking deep state
officials who all shared one thing in
common a political hatred for Donald
Trump is what Solomon writes quote there
is now growing confidence that the FBI
sudden pivot from Papadopoulos to steel
was driven by several officials all with
serious political baggage now we're
talking about Andrew McCabe page struck
and of course Bruce or and Christopher
Steele all Trump haters and according to
Solomon we're learning that Bruce or was
attempting to actually steer the FBI
so-called Russia collusion investigation
toward the phony steel dossier much
earlier than we previously thought
now several officials all with serious
political baggage as he describes him
remember this is the dossier this is all
be traced back to Hillary many of the
same figures protected her so she could
stay in the race by exonerating her
after she obviously committed felonies
and crimes and of course the DNC and
Clinton funded this phony Russian steel
dossier before the 2016 election they
funneled that money through that law
firm that money then goes to fusion GPS
they hire a foreign national a spy
Christopher steel and by the way the
wife of a high-ranking fourth highest
ranking member of the DOJ Nellie or they
put it all together op research
unverified lies against Donald Trump
no one verified this information nobody
even steel himself said under oath the
contents were raw intelligence he did
not even stand by his own dossier but it
gets worse the dossiers leaked to the
press why to influence you the American
people with Russian lies and worse than
that it spread throughout the highest
levels of our federal government by
Nellie ORS husband Bruce or again the
fourth highest ranking official at the
DOJ and then it was used as the very
basis for FISA warrants against the
Trump campaign associate Carter page and
by the way I'm told they withheld
exculpatory evidence that's the very
basis for what is now Muller's which on
or even briefed this is amazing it
starts with Hillary
the DNC they pay for it they get the
money through funneled money to an op
research group then it got hires
Christopher Steele then of course it's
being used to get FISA warrants but it's
also being funneled to Muller's pit ball
as described by the New York Times
Andrew Weissman the contents of the
dossier he's updated through Bruce or 70
contacts or and still have together
Hillary to steal to Russia right into
Rob Muller's office Russian lies you
can't make this up this is insane a web
of corruption and abuse of power
surrounding a foreign actor a phony
Russian dossier in an effort to stop
this man from becoming president and
then destroy him after he did we did
tonight reach out to all the deep state
actors mentioned in Solomon's breaking
report so far no response but tonight we
do have some positive developments to
report we have 12 Republican lawmakers
now calling on President Trump to
declassify the retracted parts of
multiple FISA documents Oh specifically
pages 10 through 12 17 to 34 that could
be released as early as tomorrow or next
week and lawmakers now believe that this
retracted information along with 302s
and the gang of eight can explain and
might have experience on Carter page and
other important information out of the
steel dossier how a fraud was committed
on a court and how an attempt to
sabotage a sitting president will have a
lot more on this tonight
also more positive FISA developments one
former official who signed off on a
Pfizer request against Paige we now know
is subject of a grand jury investigation
that's called progress finally former
FBI deputy director Andrew McCabe fired
for lying and now he may face serious
legal issues and my guess is this grand
jury we now have confirmed as convened
will look at everyone who committed a
fraud on the FISA Court who signed off
on the unverified uncorroborated phony
Russian Clinton paid-for dossier and the
lies by omission like not telling the
court even though they knew it that
Hillary paid for it all Andrew McCabe's
attorney responding to us tonight
brushing it off as nothing more than you
know the standard procedure we all know
better this is why elections matter if
elected 61 days Democrats they will
obstruct the president's effort to drain
the swamp and just like they're trying
in vain to obstruct the nomination of
Cavanagh and today New Jersey senator
likely presidential hopeful Cory Booker
he headlined the Democrats pathetic
political grandstanding threatening to
break Senate rules released confidential
documents about Cavanaugh to the general
public our own Shannon Breen and others
reporting however the documents they had
previously been released and not only
that Cory Booker was told they were
released so still he had to put on a
show based on what he already knew was
released for his adoring fans because
he's running for president I don't have
time to run it now but then he went on
to call his actions today a Spartacus
moment even though he did zero nothing
courageous he broke no rules no he faced
no consequences just a blatant play to
his base so he can run for president in
2020 but in Booker's mind he rose to the
level of a Roman gladiator risking it
all for a cause calling himself a hero
for doing absolutely nothing
it's like Colin Kaepernick going 1 and
11 and then after that of course saying
oh it's the NFL is unfair to me